in Sheffield the strain of the social
care sector is all too apparent
this is one of many Care Homes counting
the cost of Staff shortages and soaring
bills
using agency staff is necessary but
expensive as energy and food costs are
rising along with interest rates it's a
time of apprehension about how
round-the-clock care can be provided
we've seen staff leave the system
through the pandemic we can't recruit
like we used to be able to recruit we're
not competitive with the pay rates and
they're doing a fantastic job with it
within you know our care facilities
within the trust but sadly we're not
competitive fighting their corner is the
Archbishop of Canterbury with a New
Year's Day message advocating for Urgent
action and greater funding our care
system is broken
but it doesn't have to be
we can rise to the challenge of fixing
it that means action from all of us you
me families communities government
caring goes to the heart of what it
means to be human it is hard Justin
Welby wants carers to be valued more and
paid more he's highlighted how less
demanding jobs can be more lucrative
adding to the Staffing shortfall
there were 1.79 million posts in adult
social care in England last year but
only 1.62 million were filled a decrease
of three percent on the previous year
leaving 165 000 rolls empty
and the number of vacancies is only
growing year on year
Boris Johnson promised to fix the crisis
in Social care after entering down the
street in 2019 but the implementation of
reforms has been delayed by political
and economic upheaval
British sunat government committed an
extra 7.5 billion pounds in November's
Autumn budget for adult social care over
the next two years
by the head of the national care
Association says that's not enough
there's been so much under investment in
Social care despite all the rhetoric
about how much money has been released
into social care the reality is it
doesn't get to the front line so our
providers don't see it and we can't then
use that to actually be paying people
more filling care jobs would ease some
of the burden on hospitals with the most
recent data showing around 14 000
patients were ready to be discharged
after treatment but couldn't due to the
lack of social care provision available
the population is aging and less healthy
adding to the burden on an NHS lacking
resilience underscoring why fixing
social care provision is seen as a
priority for 2023 with his latest
political intervention the Archbishop of
Canterbury has made clear what's needed
finding more funding for those receiving
and providing care Rob Harris Sky News